[Music]
a greedy old farmer the school's
resident snitch spoiled young girls
children's show characters are so well
known even the terrible ones keep
watching to find out which ones made the
cut
shows get new characters added to the
main cast all the time sometimes those
editions become an important part of the
show's new dynamic like mycanigan on
friends other times the newbie can
overpower the entire show's narrative
like steve urkel on family matters
other times you get a character like
scrappy do the loud and energetic little
pup was introduced as the nephew of
scooby doo in the latter's cartoon
series in 1979
the ratings for the show were dropping
and series writer mark evaneer credits
the arrival of scrappy with keeping the
show running so it seems the great dane
puppy was fairly popular at least in the
beginning later generations of fans grew
to dislike how much attention scrappy
was getting and the way he affected the
dynamic of the main cast of scooby and
the gang scrappy's popularity sunk so
low that he was reimagined as the main
villain in the 2002 live-action
scooby-doo film when james gunn who
wrote the screenplay for the movie was
asked why he made scrappy into a villain
gunn bluntly replied scrappy is just a
completely
awful person
in a sea of superhero cartoons aimed
squarely at young boys the powerpuff
girls was a breath of fresh air it's
shown the spotlight on super powered
tween sisters blossom bubbles and
buttercup and their quest to keep their
city safe from just the most adorable
villains you can imagine
while most of the villains on the show
were portrayed as creatures and monsters
things got pretty real with the
introduction of princess morbucks
as her name indicates morbucks was a
little girl whose superpower was having
an uber-rich dad who gave his little
princess anything she wanted
princess morbucks typifies the worst
kind of spoiled children that exist in
the real world get on the board the choo
choo is spricks
[Music]
i only travel first class on my daddy's
private leader jet
she is the kind of over-entitled brat
who thinks the world owes her everything
morbucks repeatedly tries to become a
powerpuff girl with the help of her
dad's resources when that doesn't work
she tries to take out the competition by
every underhanded means available
amusingly princess morbucks might be a
parody of little orphan annie both
characters are red-haired freckled-faced
little girls while daddy morbucks sounds
quite similar to annie's adoptive father
daddy warbucks
if peppa pig is the modern flag bearer
of the troublesome children's show
protagonist archetype caillou is the og
much like peppa caiu's life revolves
around exploring the world with an
inquisitive spirit
also like peppa the dude can become
quite the little monster if he is not
allowed to do what he wants all the time
he complains non-stop about things he
does not like and throws temper tantrums
at the drop of a hat he pinched his baby
sister called his friend stupid and ran
wild in the school when sarah took him
to her class for a project to add to the
chaos it's pretty clear that much of
caillou's bad behavior is enabled by his
weak-willed parents
things got so bad that many articles
were written about how much people hated
caillou and his show today the character
is better known as a symbol of internet
hate than for his own show
you know hating caillou has gone
mainstream when the character gets
specifically called out by last week
tonight host john oliver
some hair and leave the house
imagine dennis the menace without any of
the charm or charisma and you have
norman price in a nutshell norman holds
the record for being rescued the most
number of times and roughly each time he
was responsible for his own mess
norman refuses to learn from experience
and goes right back to work getting into
trouble again while other children show
protagonists often get into trouble
because they don't know any better
norman is a much more proactive
participant you know like the million
times he caused a fire we're pretty sure
norman's reputation as a prankster will
get him sent to prison the minute he
turns 18 or if he ever steps foot
outside of his hometown where all the
grown-ups are inexplicably cool with
norman's constant life-threatening
antics
hanging upside down by his foot i should
have seen that one coming
at first the smurfs looks to be the
portrait of an ideal society as embodied
by smurf village every smurf gets one
defining trait and their jobs and
personalities are built around it in
truth some of the smurf's personalities
seem to be built around being obnoxious
tools and nothing else
somehow brainy smurf manages to be more
annoying than every other resident
clearly you two lack the verbal skills
required to explain this predicament
succinctly
supposedly brainy is the voice of reason
among his peers but he is too in love
with his own mind to be likable he
constantly brags about his intelligence
looks down on the other smurfs and acts
like he is papa smurf's second in
command despite there being no such
actual position to top it all while
brainy talks a good game he has proven
himself to be no more competent at
dealing with actual problems than the
other smurfs which means his problem
solver persona is all just an act
2003's teen titans was praised for its
complex plotlines strong central cast of
characters and believable emotional arcs
the series got a semi-spin-off in 2013
called teen titans go which was exactly
like the original except all the
returning main characters were now just
awful people in every way
robin raven beast boy starfire and
cyborg on teen titans go are like parody
versions of the teen titans characters
they rarely fight crime and are
frequently depicted more as
self-absorbed teenagers than superheroes
the creators of the show are aware that
fans of the original are not happy with
the changes made to the main characters
as producer michael jelinik told comics
alliance we decided to bring back the
original cast because they had good
chemistry and so far it's worked
for everybody except for fans of the
original show
the issue has become so hotly debated
that teen titans go did an entire
episode about its characters needing to
be more like the guys from the original
teen titans everyone knows the basic
premise of tom and jerry there is tom
the cat and jerry the mouse
[Music]
their battles have become the stuff of
legends within the confines of the house
tom belongs to
tom is the dim-witted goliath while
jerry is the quick-witted but much
tinier david as such jerry is usually
depicted as the protagonist of the
series but as you grow older you realize
how unfairly tom is depicted in the
cartoons after all the dude is a house
pet and is specifically expected to help
keep his owner's house and belongings
free of vermin on the other hand jerry
is the undesired house guest who steals
what he wants destroys house property
and even brings his pals from the wild
into the house for extended periods
who knows what kind of diseases or
dangerous bacteria jerry his nephew
nibbles or quacker the duckling have
brought into the house over the years
as you become an adult and a homeowner
you start to realize the danger posed by
rodents to your property and that's when
tom starts looking more and more like
the good guy
recess was a show that dared to ask what
if the typical american school
playground during recess became a
sophisticated small scale version of
society complete with kids being placed
in highly organized social groups and a
king to oversee the running of the
entire structure and dole out punishment
to wrongdoers the central premise of the
show might appear limited but it works
surprisingly well due to the
well-rounded nature of the characters of
the children who take part in the
recessed society however not every
character is likable least of all
randall weems randall is the school's
resident snitch which might sound like
an insult if randall wasn't so proud of
the fact throughout the show he is shown
to be completely devoted to the cause of
snitching on his fellow classmates to
his beloved teacher miss finster randall
is also shown at different points to be
a coward and a traitor to make matters
worse he is not above using information
he has on other kids to blackmail them
for favors
honestly if he wasn't such a scrawny
little weasel that you occasionally feel
sorry for randall would be one of the
most despicable characters in fiction
blonde pigtailed and angelic-looking
angelica pickles is a prime example of a
wolf in sheep's clothing the cousin of
tommy and dill pickles angelica served
as one of the main villains on rugrats
which is a truly awful statement when
you remember the heroes of the series
are literal toddlers that angelica
delights in terrorizing at just three
years old angelica is a spoiled
headstrong little tyrant who can
communicate with adults as well as
infants
here's your pudding angelica oh that's
okay uncle stu i'm not hungry anymore
instead of acting as a bridge of
understanding between the two groups
angelica uses her advantage entirely for
her own ends she has also frequently
played the babies off against each other
pinned the blame for her cat's actions
on tommy's dog convince the other babies
that chucky is an alien and faked a
ransom note to get free candy honestly a
grown-up version of angelica would
probably be a full-blown psychopath
who'd cyber bully her classmates as a
joke fortunately teenage angelica who
showed up later in the series is shown
to have calmed down somewhat and isn't
nearly as awful as her three-year-old
self
farmers and old men are generally
treated kindly on children's shows they
are often depicted as fatherly and full
of wisdom or harmless backdrop
characters to whatever the protagonist
of the show has going on at the moment
eustis from courage the cowardly dog
bucks this trend by being an actively
awful person as the title suggests the
show is about a dog named courage who is
an extreme coward
however his cowardice does not stop him
from protecting his owners eustis and
his wife muriel while muriel is every
bit the simple warm-hearted farmer
stereotype you could hope for her
husband is a crotchety greedy
mean-spirited jerk who constantly goes
out of his way to make courage's life
miserable the main villains on the show
are aliens and otherworldly monsters but
viewers realize as grown-ups how much
more realistic and compelling a villain
eustis was than the villain of the weak
creatures his habit of addressing
courage as stupid dog putting on scary
masks to send courage into a frenzied
panic and taking his irritation out on
the family pet all line up depressingly
well with real-life cases of animal
abuse really if courage hadn't been so
loyal the best thing he could have done
was just let the monsters take eustis
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you